来来来胸围胸围9698腰围的话是72807280来裙长的话是113
来这个裙子谁要谁来抠这个应该是新款来这个谁要谁来抠4949抠个8
4949扣8谁要谁来扣谁要谁来过49扣个8
来喜欢的姐姐衣服49扣849扣个8来来来
来喜欢姐姐衣服
能急死打电话没人接我跟你说能急死
来这个这个是吉尔的m码面料锯纸
吉尔的这个直包腿的裙来这一款包腿的这个裙吉尔的吉尔的
m码m码啊腰后面带松紧腰腰后面带松紧前面有一排装饰扣来这一款腰围
可以拉到72盆尾96100两口子没有一个接手机的来长度的话92
长度92长度92来这一款谁要谁来扣来3939扣33939谁要谁来扣个3
哎急死
滚 House
来这一款来就帮我们看这个外搭
没有酷也没有酷 height
面料具纸面料巨指的
来这一款
没有
扣也没有扣牙
来这个开山外搭
来
胸围胸围106 110
106可以拉伸到110
长度的话是108
来这个外搭
谁要谁来扣9块
有两个颜色啊
9块9块扣9
9块9块谁要谁来扣个9
哎呀能急死我
来这个咖色的
上面包屯底下鱼尾的
来这个鱼尾裙
咖色咖色
来左边有隐形拉链的
这个腰后面带松紧的啊
来来来
腰围腰围66可以拉伸到
臀围92可以拉到98
92 98
裙长73
来这个裙子谁要谁来扣
19 19扣1扣1啊
来喜欢的姐姐就给我19扣1
包臀的这个裙子啊
谁要谁来扣
来口19扣1啊
后面的白色连衣裙好
两口子真的一个接电话的都没有
是这个吗
亲爱的
是不是这个弹力的吗
是这个吗
这个是没有弹力的
这个是马甲裙
啊好
面料很好的啊
面料很好的看到了吗
里边的质量做工都好
原来49现在只需要29
给你量一量你听一听好吧
挺厚的单层单层
单层来胸围104106104106
长度的话是115长度115下边热板
这个颜色说实话夏天是可以穿的
但是我觉得这个是春夏秋都可以穿
等到春秋天的时候咱里边可以叠穿
看到了吗
它是单层
看到了没有就一层
原来49现在29你看你要不要
这个我说实话我前几天挂后面挂一条卖一条
姐姐我再看看ok点个关注吧小妹
哎呀
点个关注点个关注
急死人了
我跟你说一个接电话的都没有
两口子一个接电话
你说干啥呢
这看不到字
你知道吗
小的很
来这个条文条文
这个马甲裙前面打个结的来这个条文
条文的这个马甲裙
马甲裙前面打个结
黑的
非条文的黑条文的来胸围胸围104108104
108腰围981698106裙长100裙长100来这个裙子
谁要谁来扣来2929扣个六 R19 二十九谁要谁来扣个六 谁要谁来扣个六来这种感觉是人绵的感觉是人绵的有谈刎地的 有谈力 有谈腻的有谈腻的 古里 Male Ngai 我呕 Mid cartel lucidae mine out, I run my body out at least me all day long Oh I want to Whatskov
来这一款衬衫
来给大家看看这个牌子的
M码面料锯纸
面料锯纸这个牌子的一个条纹衬衫
蓝条纹的
蓝白条纹的
蓝色的底白色的条
来这款衬衫
咱们来量一下
你们听一下底下有弧度
底下有弧度的
这个衬衫我觉得男生女生都可以穿
只要尺寸合适
来胸围108
胸围是108
长度的话是77
来这一款谁要谁来扣29
29扣个2
29 29扣个2
M码面料锯纸的
M码面料锯纸
谁要谁来扣29扣个2
29扣个2
来写了几个字
,来这个裤子
来给宝们看这个牌子的M码面料锯纸
M码M码面料锯纸加圆纸的
来这款裤子直筒的直筒
腰是半腰松拧
两边有鞋拉口袋
屁股后面是一个光板
屁股后面是一个光板光板
这个还挺厚的
感觉春秋天穿腰围64
可以拉到86
臀围12绒可以拉到12绒
腰围64可以拉到86
腰围16可以拉到126
当场39
裤长97
来这个裤子谁要谁来裤
谁要谁来裤
扣个3
谁要谁来扣个3
这个燕麦色
来喜欢的姐姐就扣39
扣3
扣个3
剪刀
来这个卫衣
这个牌子的
这个牌子里边还是毛圈的
看到了吗
这个牌子这个牌子的
来这个
来这个卡其色的这个卫衣
这个卫衣
来咱们来看一下
前面短一点后面长一点
它这里有一个
有一个染色
我看它是什么面料啊
我看一下它是什么面料
它写的是棉35巨值65
5L到6L
6L前面短后面长
但这个我不确定能不能洗得掉
这里这里有一块看到了吗
来这一款你们谁要的话
我给大家便宜
正常卖的话39
这是新款
胸围的话是136 140
136可以拉起到140
长度的话
前面67后面72
来这一款谁要谁来抠
来这一款19吧
19抠1
19抠个1
后面串了一点的这个色
串了一点的这个红色
来谁要谁来抠19
19抠1
这是啥
这是个卫衣
卫衣
但是它有串色
本来这个是新款
棉35巨值65
这个大5L到6L的
5L到6L的
手你打电话来
你干啥了干啥了干啥了
我给你反了反了
打你打明明的打你了都能干啥
都没人接
玩玩看一扫一
出去玩了
看着都热
这个就是春秋天穿呀
春秋天穿呀
这个是新款
正常卖的话要卖39
它后面有一个色差
这我便宜了挺多的
如果喜欢的话就一扣
不喜欢就不扣
能接受那一点回家洗洗
但不知道能不能洗掉
这个是泥
来这个马甲
黑色的这个马甲
牌子是这个牌
前面有拉链
来这个马甲
花纹的
来胸围
102 104
长度的话80
来这款谁要
29扣零
29 29
谁要谁来扣个零
来这个马甲很好看
那个是泥
那个是泥脏的
有直插兜
前面这个有拉链的
来谁要谁来扣
29 29
谁要谁来扣个二
好看好看的这个马甲
好看好看的
谢谢我亲爱的鲜黄
帮我发了那么多图片
来这个马甲
棉马甲
有拉链的紫色戴帽子的
紫色戴帽子的棉马甲
棉马甲
来这款戴帽戴帽的
来来来
打那里打那里
还没有还没好
来胸围98
100 98
长度的话65
来这款谁要29
29扣5
29 29
谁要谁来扣个五
棉马甲棉马甲
谁要谁来扣